what have you done with your daughter
how old is your daughter now you have
one child right yes she's almost 19.
okay this would be fascinating like how
have you
parented her well i've parented her with
a lot of uh bloodshed meaning
i've i've messed up and effed up a lot
so
yeah but through that i learned and i
teach others how to mess up less so i've
at least used her as the muse
scapegoat to help other parents not do
it because i get it when i make a
mistake i'm like [ __ ] and this is why i
did it and now let me teach other people
so i have to have a muse and she's my
muse but i've tried to do what i teach
you know at least half of the time which
is to release her
to her own life
and not take it as
an affront or an applause to my life
it's her own life
and i've constantly given her the baton
to make those decisions you know what
you want to eat check in with your body
you know what you want to wear check in
with your body and if i do have an
opinion
i i say it age appropriately so now
she's 19 you can't really have an
opinion with a 19 year old but if i see
her dressing you know a bit
too risque
uh instead of saying don't instead of
saying you know don't be a [ __ ] which is
what i want to say i would say
i'll say instead
i would reconsider
you know how close to showing your
nipples you are you know i'll be i'll
try and tell her in a gentle way because
i want her to make her own decision
you know and i can't what i want to do
is lock her in a box and keep her safe
and protected but i know i can't so as
parents we need to release children to
their own life wisdom to their own body
wisdom to their own self-wisdom
and it's hard with with kids because
they don't have much wisdom so it's like
uh hello you have zero wisdom i see you
being a total idiot [ __ ]
dr shivali how do i release her to a
wisdom when there's no wisdom
yeah but but giving your child your
wisdom is a sure-fire way that they
won't develop their wisdom
pattern
yeah so it's really hard though as i i
feel for parents because there's nobody
more idiotic than a teenager really
they're really really not so smart and
so you have to really have a lot of
patience and trust
to release them to their own wisdom
hoping that they have it but i will tell
you out of just you know taking myself
out of the funny part of it is that
actually we all do have wisdom
it just takes cultivation
so i know as a parent if i just let her
make her mistakes enough wisdom will
come where does wisdom come from it
comes from error it comes from trial and
practice and for making mistakes so
releasing children to making their own
mistakes is torturous for the parent
because we know
what they should do
but allowing them to experience the the
casualty of their own foolishness
is
counterintuitively the way to create
wisdom
you know
yeah i mean that's i i'm not a parent
but i can only imagine how hard it is to
give them enough rope to hang themselves
and you know it's part of the growth you
know my my parents let me move to
england when i was 16 years old and left
high school and lived there on my own
without family and i'm sure that i know
that's what helped me grow and become
the person that i did because i had that
enough rope and of course i hung myself
a little bit but
i'm curious like what happens from a
young age i feel like they're like i
mean i go up to a kid and i'm like you
know you see this little girl and you
think she looks adorable and you're like
oh my god you're so cute but i'm like no
i'm like wow did you pick your outfit
out today you you know and like starting
to ask questions from a different
perspective and these are just my like
tiny little ways that i approach
children and like you know that was a
great question i'm so glad you asked it
and things that aren't about the
superficial so
anyway the point is is like how what can
what have you done with your daughter to
because you can't
completely avoid the patterning that you
have like you are living your life and
by nature you're
it's
transmitting it to her by proximity
um so what are the tools that you try
and embed in a young child early on that
gives them the
ability to see what's going on have
accountability be able to make decisions
for themselves things like that what
what can you do at the younger ages
yes so the most powerful thing we can do
as parents is take care of our own
expectations
and fulfill our own cup of fulfillment
and happiness so that we are not sucking
our children and the identity of being a
parent
and using that identity to fulfill
ourselves which is what many parents do
they use their children as proxies
surrogate
you know buckets to fill their own
well-being
your kid is your your kid that they are
they only their own destiny you are
their guide
and that's about it but people equate
parenting as i own you i control you and
you are here to make me feel comfortable
and good about being a parent and that's
the mess up right so becoming aware that
we have to become whole in ourselves is
the best gift you can give your kids
when your kid sees that mom is happy
even when i get a c grade and mom is
happy regardless of whether i never get
an a grade
that is so freeing to the kid
when they see that mom is happy when i
win the baseball trophy or the the
hockey tournament and that's what gives
her happiness
now you subconsciously put pressure on
the kid
that that oh shoot i exist for my mom
parents need to exist for themselves
kids needs need to exist for from for
themselves so i was aware of that as a
mom and really had my own career my own
fulfilling practices
and tried to do both you know be there
for the kid because kids need parents a
lot
but also be there for my own fulfillment
so my joy was not based on the kid
there's this adage in parenting
you're only as happy as your least happy
child
and i get that but that's a bunch of
[ __ ] you should be happy no matter
what your kid is unhappy why is why you
unhappy right but that's what we
propagate subconsciously we teach
parents to be enmeshed and dependent on
their children no
teach kids that you're going to be happy
of course it pains you that they're in
pain but pain is a beautiful thing so
the next thing i would say for parents
to do is honor feelings let feelings be
feelings let the kid have their own
feelings we try to control our
children's feelings we suppress our
children's feelings because they make us
uncomfortable
so when you're comfortable with your own
self you allow your kid to be
comfortable and then i would say
especially if you're a mother of a girl
be very careful about your own body
image be careful about how you're
communicating your own life story to
your daughter especially and also to
your son
you know how are you communicating how
women should be treated how are you
communicating how worthy you feel in
your essence versus your exterior and
you know i remember once my daughter at
a party in front of everyone i was
wearing a sleeveless dress
said oh mom let me see oh look at your
jiggly arm show people your jiggly like
helicopters right and i was like is this
kid the nut job i'm gonna punish her you
know what the hell is wrong with her but
of course i laughed at myself because i
had done enough work and i was like
outed this is what kids will do you know
they will point out all your flaws
because they don't see it as flaws so i
was like
here you go everybody and i made
everybody show their helicopter arms and
then i told my daughter
so sad you don't have your helicopter
arms yet because you can't fly yet and
look at me i've got plenty something
like that
but my instinct was to get upset my
instinct was to say i don't have
helicopter arms i have muscle look at my
muscle up here this is down here and
justify and defend
but you know or one day my daughter came
and said oh mommy
you know uh i don't want to get fat or
something or i don't want to something
about fat and i said i wanted to say to
her my reaction again was like are you
are you so silly you're so skinny i wish
i was skinny like you right that was my
instinct
but my because i knew this was coming
and you know when you're mother of a
daughter you have to be aware of these
issues i said to her i said if you're
fat you're fat if you're skinny you're
skinny today you're fat tomorrow you're
skinny
love your body no matter what maya
something like that you know but my
instinct again was to adulate skinny
them because culture adulates skinny
bodies so you have to be mindful of
these messages you know and let me tell
you even though i was mindful i really
messed up so it's not like some
perfection that i'm trying to convey
i'm just conveying an aspiration
and to be careful you know but we don't
have to be so perfect because no matter
what you do you're going to mess up
because it's a lifelong journey of so
many moments and no one is perfect you
know
the whole the whole the whole vibe of it
smells like codependency would that be
the right way to describe especially
maybe
i mean maybe and maybe it's just a
generational thing in patterning but it
seems worse in women
yeah it's worse than women because women
have been trained that their identity is
through the relationship
so
that's how why mothers enmesh with their
children more
and part of it is because we are
caregivers so we are lovely but our
loveliness becomes codependent in
measurement very quickly because we've
been trained from an early age
can you do can you actually just give a
good explanation of codependency because
i think these are the things too that
you know we hear it
and oh my god i will i would have never
said i'm codependent i'm like i'm a
strong woman i
buy my own houses i do my own things i
make my own money i'm you know all kinds
of reasons why i don't feel like i'm not
codependent and then i realized i'm
totally codependent well i was much more
codependent and um so i think it's i
think it's a great great time to just
explain what that is um
because you know
50 of people probably have it you know
yeah so codependency
is a specific condition
uh which is different from
interdependency
okay so codependency is a psychological
term that we throw around
which signifies that your identity is
really
dependent on the other person's moods
emotions and energy
so you can't hold on to your own
autonomous connection with yourself
and allow the other person to have their
own connection with yourself which is a
healthy interdependence but instead you
get deeply affected by the other
person's moods energies emotions and
thought processes so there's this
entangling
that we do and women tend to do it more
again because our nature is to care but
then culture has really effed us up in
telling us that oh caring is a good
person and a good person
really cares so therefore really caring
is managing the other person's moods and
emotions and that's where we go into the
other person's lane
and we mess it up
right so then we become codependent what
that means in layman's terms is we lose
ourselves in the relationship and i tell
people all the time you came last
you didn't lose yourself you came last
um and you can only blame the other
person so much because if you stay in a
toxic relationship then it's all on you
right
what one time it's on them two times
it's on them three months it's on them
six years it's on them but 25 years is
on you right
so that's where you have to take full
responsibility for your for our
co-creation
what are some ways that we can double
check if we're being codependent or not
i'm kind of curious about it from a
codependent side which you know i'm
really into attachment theory and
then maybe go in we'll go into the other
side of it where it's on the other end
of the spectrum because it ten
and uh and you're the professional but
there's a lot of both of those right
there's there's a lot of the codependent
anxious and then there's a lot of the
dismissive avoidant kind of
um disassociative um so like
two extremes right one is a boy
personality and one is insecure
anxious personality right right
either
right and they can both and they both
source from a very like how do you get
to each of those attachments and then if
we could go into each attachment and and
style of of relating and patterning and
how like just ways we can check in with
ourself as to whether or not we're in
one of those
like where does it source from because
how do you become one or the other
okay so it comes from childhood right so
the anxious uh insecure type are is
temperamental
where they they learned to read other
people's moods because they were more
sensitive they were able to read so they
began to base their psyche on the other
person's energies the ins the more
disorganized avoidant type personality
uh is more compartmentalized less
enmeshed and they just deny and
they're more masculine energy you know
so it could come from temperament it
could come from your own parenting and i
always tell people don't worry about
where it comes from
look at what it is
doesn't matter what is it now it doesn't
matter what you were yesterday it
doesn't matter but what are you
currently and the person can say
something like well i'm constantly upset
and affected
that's it so if you're constantly upset
and affected
you have to look at why and the person
will say because he because she because
they and it's the same cycle right so no
it isn't because of them it's because of
your co-creation so
become aware of how you're setting up
the dynamics for you to be upset
yeah they're doing them beautifully but
you're doing you beautifully so i often
tell very empathic women who are often
in relationships with more narcissistic
men
yeah they are doing their narcissism
down pat but they can only succeed
because you're doing your empathic
bleeding empath boundaryless you know
spineless human don't hat right you're
not able to check in with yourself and
stand up for yourself so the narcissist
is more narcissistic so each creates the
monster in the other